[Musique]
pour une hypothétique année
chez nous l'hiver qu'on est gelé mais
l'été on est gelato la glace au chocolat
italienne c'est vraiment quelque chose
parce qu'ils la faune très ferme très
goûteuse je suis un vrai plaisir
montréal est de souche dit non pas guéri
a fréquenté l'université du gelato à
bologne en italie avant d'ouvrir cette
gelateria au centre-ville alors c'est
troisième anniversaire pour les
aquitains dans le coin
ils sont des milliers à passer par ces
grandes écoles industriels destinés
surtout à vendre des machines et des
produits tout près chaque artisan peut
ensuite perfectionné son métier à sa
guise
d'ailleurs avant oui on se croirait à
rome on essaye de lui aussi formé en
italie vincenzo connaît ses classiques
bacciochi et le chocolat praliné
classique de paix rue jean zay bayonnais
donc 20 mars à la raisin et jaune d'oeuf
et le pana cote
noisette ma préférée c'est dense comme
goussé c'est quelque chose qu'il y ait
vraiment vous cherchez
le suivant l'accumulation plus
d'ailleurs 30 culte d'aton le vraiment
moi îles samoa examen des subtilités nom
au nouveau théâtre / ça qu'on veut
ayant appris le métier la banque
d'italie en calabre d'un monsieur que
cette année c'est ça cadre 43e année
j'essaie de recréer en fait que je
faisais avec on utilise bien du vrai
lait entier mais avec des bases
alimentaires du sucre et des additifs de
textures et de couleurs le tout a été
conçu et préparé en usine
pour les saveurs les avants d'artificiel
sont monnaie courante
mais l'artisan peut privilégier les
produits naturels de qualité à condition
d'en payer le prix oui si on t'a 2.1 2.2
kg blonde 225 dollars certaines classes
italiennes contiennent des oeufs mais
qui sont déjà dans la préparation
mais ce sont déjà mélangé déjà proposé
déjà pasteurisé donc ça facilite
beaucoup la chose pour lars quand on
parle de gelato c'est quoi la grande
différence l'action ba tiers tournent à
une vitesse beaucoup plus basses enjeux
communs 20% des cantiques avec une glace
et souvent je parle de 30 à 50% vers
l'autre grande grande différence avant à
quantité de gurs le cas de la gelato
étant composés à base de lait et donc
ont un produit qui roulent en 4 8% de
mathias ça serait l'idéal du goûter ma
joie car sommes interdits partout à tous
les coins de rue ils y ont suspendu je
dirais tu es liens la bataille juste
deux qui font encore la traditionnelle
ça donne le goût du voyage tellement
soyeux
voici les femmes et à l est pas l'état
c'est je peux dire c'est ma culture
mexicaine d'origine perla silva est
littéralement tombé dedans lorsqu'il
était petit c'est quoi les pannes et as
en fait les pas les tasses de sorts des
desserts glacés
c'est un dessert complet partager en
famille entre amis en tout le temps
sortent aussi fait chaud le mexique avec
la chaleur et ses plages publiques
revendiqué la paternité du fabuleux
d'état a fait les souvenirs ça remontait
jusqu'à ma grand-mère et
sortu l epal et assez il vient blâma à
chercher les côtés de sauver les fruits
qu'on préfère une mix des fruits des
deux fruits alors on peut s'amuser à
malley cherchant des signes reviendra
mac un peu s'est marié dans la cuisine
aujourd'hui les palettes à ce sont
presque devenus des oeuvres d'art ils
sont une invitation à l'exotisme on en
retrouve de plus en plus ici dans les
bars laitiers les marchés et les
festivals ils ont souvent des
combinaisons inattendues match à noix de
coco qui oui moi je me rappelle ma
nounou phases au sol lorsque l'état
jeune jean gonthier connaît bien des
sucettes glacées il donne des formations
aux propriétaires de crémerie pour
fabriquer ces pop mexicaine c'est
christiane toute la palette qu'on l'a
fait donc ici nous avons le rejet de
mojito framboise mangue citron pina
colada fraises et rhubarbe pistache à
nana peu importe les fruits que vous
utilisez il faut avoir un taux de fruits
dans l'hérault soixante dix pensaient
faire des dalles et à ce citron ou
encore aux framboises ce n'est pas si
difficile je suis un peu de sucre un peu
doblo vient juste comme assurer un peu
que notre palette as beau être vraiment
glace est parce que c'est l'eau qui gèle
donc l'eau qui est à l'intérieur du
fluide vraiment nous aider à faire un
bon la balade à danser votre préféré la
wii en fait mon préféré on fait la
mangue sucre au et jus de citron pour
équilibrer le ph on garde
la moitié du fuite pour les mettre à
l'intérieur de nos modes plus que le
fruit vrai dans un milieu acide de ce
qu'ils vont ressortir le goût du fruit
et vous voyez quand même temps qu'on a
beaucoup moins d'eau et du sud à cause
que la mangue au sa part d'autres
ont commencé oui ce serait son patron à
mettre un élu parce qu'il faut avoir
assez d'espacé pour que le jus puce
prendre sa place s'il bat roddick s agit
bien là
et on place au congélateur comme ça ce
type de congélateurs industriel permet
de congeler les palets tasse en 12
minutes
howard s impressionnant
ça sent la framboise et l'âme angle
l'ont volé les beaux morceaux demande
s'il perd là elle nous a préparé trois
pas les tasses à saveur mexicaine ait
fana mais les tamarins c'est un fruit et
couleurs blanc
j'adore / je vais souvent goûté avec du
sel et des marais mais comme ça ça fait
quelque chose de frais avec le côté
acidulé la loyale ces entrées blanches
et roses et les fameuses hibiscus qui
est couleurs franches à 16 heures
locales
là